if my hands seem like they're you know I
apologize
oh yeah you know my favorite part of
that video what my favorite trainer and
I know Shirley Leonard yep my favorite
tears you go oh my god you're filming
that this is not I didn't know yeah I
swear to God oh my god no oh my god
let's just start filming no listen this
is crazy is sly said sly said so I said
the person over there he goes hey get
this on video you crazy get this on
video cuz he was ti I swear to God I had
no idea I swear to God I didn't know I
would tell you I didn't I didn't know
but this is I got I got so much longer
we were doing this for [ __ ] 10
minutes how many people are like dude
and I got a dealio whoa I got a I got a
thing was hitting me in the ribs and
pulling it back and that was this thing
it was for the Super Bowl
yeah and look at sly watching so I said
you made right there he starts hitting
so I said you made the right choice in
fact yeah sly looks good man looks
[ __ ] great
Sugar Ray looks better than all you guys
dude unbelievable yeah I told you I said
how do you see why what's your CRT team
assembled now he goes I'm vain that's
what this I don't think he's doing
charity at all I think he's just I love
you for that
that's why I love you you think he's
done everyone not householders so for
the chicks
yeah I don't know and you and me and me
daliyah i'm suspect on he's gay you walk
did I go oh hey bro there's no one
around you want steroids he is hot dude
I just some tablet I spent lift Daniel
yeah I get out lift and works 40 should
put on muscle like this he is right now
dude I just I never really left and I'm
lifting and and eating right up and then
I get it man he goes yeah I'm lifting
her all right I know all that I hear you
that's that's great dude okay there's no
one rounded youngster what's he goes God
get out of here but I went yeah all
right dude he's definitely not Mary he's
definitely not Chris would never know
well I mean you know no I'm still afraid
of Chris of steroids Oh Dobie that's
dear I mean I'll help you better here
I'll take what God yeah I don't know
yeah I don't
he doesn't look muscular right he just
looks good he just looks like he's just
yeah that's my favorite I had no good
actor senior good I swear to God
I say can I Instagram this who's the
other black guy ah let's race friend a
guy named Jerry do you calm ray-ray I
did not lie wait what's up ray ray call
him champ or a comrade I come away so
blow ray little race
ray ray really yeah no don't do that
don't know ray ray no comrade okay don't
you call no disrespect I call champ you
call ray I come ray yeah Oh God I come I
come ray yeah you call Sylvester
Stallone's fly though even his kids call
fly it's great it's kids don't call dad
they call him sly it's hilarious sly
what what this kids clone fly everybody
calls him stuff wrong with that why why
they call him slack you tell you Brian
or bright huh you kids call your bride
uh my daughter does sometimes just to
annoy me
it's so funny he couldn't be closer to
his daughter so it's [ __ ] hilarious
his daughters like this is why I never
leave like go back to that let me see
him in Rambo let me see in the Rambo oh
there you go when he's young his body
that's awesome
kids got a body bite it up body the [ __ ]
up do you like the game I did like the
game I liked it very much now I was
rooting because our boy Tarkas even
works for the 49ers we have a couple
friends we know Jed York yeah but Kansas
City I don't know anything about
football I sent you that video because
here's me here's me here's what I want
to do it like my uber drivers or
whatever
start talk to me about football asked me
about Kansas City and stuff like that
and what I think know what you think
hence idiom I tell you my home
the real deal he's the real deal people
are doing this thing believeth I do this
this is me I don't know but I just start
to parrot you and I go it's its way
they're so rare to get a quarterback
like this because you know I mean look
what they did with Archie 3 they forced
him in the pocket now he's gonna be back
for you babe the backfield and those
holes quick coke
you got it the thing is if you run
they're gonna force you to pass if
you're pass it gonna force you to run
that's the nfm you say you some guys can
just have that they have that x-factor
we do instead slice else oh I'll do it
everybody cuz I'm I got yeah yeah drops
you understand yeah I parrot [ __ ] yeah
but I do think that might might my
assessment was Mahone and Andy Reid
Lopes mahomes an enemy said let's just
hurry up offense they scored and that
would that just change the momentum
that's just [ __ ] changed everything
and they've come back from behind I
think in the past three times yeah
and that just that shows his greatness
he's so good so good they're you know
what better game here's what I think I
don't think at the end of the day maybe
better team the better team one right or
no I don't know San Cisco is pretty stat
phenom the thing is as Kyle Shannon Kyle
Shanahan who I love would grow up and
say neighborhood
Kyle Shanahan you know when he was the
offensive coordinator for the Falcons
when they're up 21 points in the Super
Bowl years ago when they played the
Patriots and lost so he has like this
weird kind of it's almost like play
calling me not to lose when they get
ahead
it's very strange without the NFL you
get up by that many points kind of game
over yeah kind of game oh yeah let's you
playing Tom Brady no what do you mean
playing not to loosen not no he stops -
I got him the head so they start to turn
away his nervous yeah trying to yeah
waste time run the ball more being a
little more cautious instead of just
playing what got your head for the gate
go and and as the head coach are you the
primary shot caller or your option anis
sometimes they're not sometimes their
offensive coordinator is offense
sometimes the head coach is a defense
specialist it might have more influence
on the defense than offense or sometimes
the head coach he'll come up with the
game plan but there's offense defense
coordinator and head coach conscious
waking game time here let's go for on
fourth down or let's run this player
this but
there's often Stephens corner you're
talking to your your people the whole
time but ultimately it's like to be in
the president it sure comes down to your
comes down you're uncertain but Kyle
Shahan runs the he's one of the coaches
who do run the offense really like Shawn
McVeigh because he once it runs the
office cuz he was not offensive to
certain coaches that actually they do
all they do run and then when the
quarterback you see the quarterback
sitting down looking at you know the
tabla yeah what's he doing there - he's
looking at the defense line up to
certain formations what coverage there
and how they're hiding
you know blitzes and certain kinds and
coverages just so we can recognize it as
the game yeah what they're doing in
certain packages is so fascinating with
the incredibly detailed
let's lie pass him home so good he
recognized the off the defense smart
analyzes this market should be like a
finite and he didn't play great you'd
have a good game yeah he was off well he
just but but he like he's that poise
under pressure of just being able to do
it and just throw in those balls till
his daddy was a professional baseball
player so he may he played baseball to
or he played some baseball and then his
uncle's a-rod he was hit by a rod was
his uncle to say what yeah applied by
blood I don't think guys love but he
writes his Godfather so a rod like put
him in the position to to but a rod put
him in the position to like you know
just he he doesn't crumble under
pressure like the moment can't get big
enough for wow he's that guy that's a
huge part of it also a big sturdy kid
much bigger much taller than you would
think and just thick and strong and fast
goddamn he does everything well runs
throws everything and just a winner boys
about to get paid he is right about to
get paid stud what a stud Wow and he's
24 I think 24 25 is so crazy I know
right
[ __ ] he looks so yeah how you the
biggest contract NFL history you think
so yep really let me think about it
NFL MVP well he's super MVP worth his
weight and yeah [ __ ] oh he's the most
famous again he doesn't later he's not
cute girl something where's your alright
you know it's go school yeah well now
it's about school now let me see his
girl since high school alright they been
dating okay it's good because you know
this girl
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]